if a non-fighter wants to learn physical
self-defense
where and how can they start first of
all in your head stop calling yourself a
non-fighter
whatever that is every bore every dude
that comes out of the vagina and in my
opinion has the capability to be a
fighter if he just so
chooses to be and i think every dude is
a fighter
so first turn the switch on stop being a
pussy
all right sorry go ahead no that's
actually a factual information yeah
the eyes our eyes are in the front of
our head right now
the top or the side yeah they're not on
the side over here we're watching out
for the attacker
we're the predator yeah so you're you
are correct i can't see
right right here i can't even see what's
right here
turn my head so yeah that's okay that's
good
start with the mindset where you're
going from there um
so you're asking the question it's
really to me just a choice
anything's better than nothing and then
of the
whatever that anything is then there's
degrees of better there's
i don't think there's like a right or
wrong you know you could do krav maga
you could do muay thai you can box you
can do jiu jitsu
hill crossfit has self-defense now but
anything is better than nothing but then
the degrees of
what that is get you know i think a
little bit better
for me the foundational martial arts are
always the best to start
wrestling boxing muay thai chuchitsu you
know you you step up
against a guy that has a little bit of
knowledge in any one of those
they're a pain in the ass and let alone
if he has a little bit in
all of them or he's really good at one
of them just kiss your ass goodbye
you're going to sleep yeah yeah you've
you've heard me say the same exact thing
actually yeah jiu-jitsu
i always say start with jiu jitsu uh the
reason is
you already have a natural defense for
someone trying to strike you and that is
run away
you know if someone say if you're coming
at me and you you got a knife or
whatever i'm gonna run from you yeah
it's okay it's defense i'm being
defensive i'm running away from you
that sucks no no i'm saying like if
somebody came
oh i'm 100 agreeing with you i was like
hey bro give me your wallet i was like
gotta catch me first yeah exactly
exactly unless you have something that
travels a few the only reason
you have to defend yourself is if i grab
ahold of you
and now you've got to know how to
grapple some kind of grapple right you
got to be able to get out of that
and so that's why i say start with jiu
jitsu
and then for me boxing only because i
think it's easier to learn than muay
thai
and you want to learn a little bit of
basic striking and then
muay thai and wrestling i mean
you can just get start getting into them
too but there's
the the beautiful thing is in america
right now there's all these places to
train
there's a jiu jitsu school in every city
every corner
i mean i live in san diego so i guess
it's actually completely out of control
here
i could have taken you on a tour of like
74 totally legit
uh jiu jitsu places in san diego and now
they all have muay thai they all have
boxing
i mean everyone's doing everything and
so
what do you think about like the
self-defense oriented martial arts
so would you be talking about like krav
maga yeah i think those are good
augments
so i i think once you have a base of jiu
jitsu boxing wrestling and muay thai
then i think cool now learn some krav
maga because they're gonna start looking
at weapons they're gonna start looking
at knives i think it's good
but i think from the beginning i would
rather invest my time in
the the big four yep 100 agree
get the foundational pillars right right
you can build anything you want on that